[Applause]
alright that was really really rich and
I hope you all feel the same that's a
lot to digest and it's all very good
stuff too so my question starts with an
observation and it seems that you are
all in the business of epiphany making
like you are producing epiphany and so
what my question is you know what does
it mean for you personally
professionally or as a citizen in the
world to be modified by these epiphanies
that you are producing like what does
that end up looking like to you what
kind of humans are you becoming as a
consequence of these epiphanies
impinging on your lives like who are we
or who are you becoming as a consequence
of these new things that you're learning
that you're making visible anyone can
start I think it's very question I I
don't think of my own work that way but
I think it's a productive question to
think about epiphany as as an opening
and particularly when we have so many
interesting people here together here on
this panel from different fields and
perspectives and yet kind of converging
around questions of invisibility and
materiality and politics in one way or
another I don't know what wouldn't and
maybe I want to push you on that because
you're very much like one of like the
people in media studies that would like
no listening about infrastructure and
that's a different way of seeing than
what media studies was before when like
people were looking at images in there
it isn't stuff like that and like
obviously you started looking at the
world differently because I would have
hung out with you and you're like oh
this is the place where like this cable
goes from here to here and that's how it
is
than that you like you're literally
seeing the world differently yeah it is
true that I mean my whole interested in
infrastructure was because I was
socialized as a young woman to not be
interested in how things work and how
they're set up in some ways being a
media scholar I've become more and more
interested in electric in electrical
engineering and I remember seeing one of
my first papers I ever wrote was about
TV repair and realizing that if
something broke down one of my
electronics broke down I didn't have the
knowledge or even the inclination to
like crack something open to try to
figure out how to address it or fix it
and so I feel like any epiphany work
that has happened for me has been about
like dealing with issues and questions
of technological literacy and and how
that is a political issue knowing how
things work where they're located who
owns them how they're structured is
important and it's not something that's
readily apparent all the time especially
when we're getting into the kind of
things that you're looking at Trevor to
or the chemical issues or even the
electromagnetic spectrum you know how to
find languages for making intelligible
phenomena that have incredible bearing
and power over us as society's tried to
get the conversation going so that I
kind of entered on the point of thinking
about land body relations and my kind of
work right now is about thinking about
decolonial approaches to chemical
exposure and that along with edgy has
require all sorts of changes so one is
learning how to do horizontal
collaboration using consensus in
research with others so really kind of
getting out of individual research modes
has been something that is changing I
would say like the question changes me
another part of the project is trying to
figure out how do you bring questions of
the coloniality actually into labs so
that's the kind of question that
involves working collectively and
bringing different kinds of people
together in lab places and kind of
questioning like clues in a lab and
what's there what does it mean to bring
black indigenous futurists together to
think this question which is another
part of the project so that brings in a
lot of art questions and a lot of
questions of the imagination and
aesthetic production and then I think
another side is that because as a kind
of a white skinned person I've been able
to exist in the Academy without talking
a lot about myself but this project has
like really required me to be more
exposed as a person in academia which is
sometimes a good space but not always a
safe space and so that's another thing
that it's required of me is to be more
vulnerable and open a church yeah about
the picture me I guess for a geek like
me appear in the strange world because
we we tend to be satisfied by various
italic things such as an equation that
happens to work out in the laboratory or
whatever but I say sort of the the
projects are described maybe it would
have been obvious to a social order or a
humanist like you but of course you have
your ring component - have you reached
the moment all the time yes that's true
but hybrid is Eureka moments can
actually create such strong emotions to
people you know I saw people actually
actively writing hate blogs about touch
life because while you know we're
enabling their government to do these
awful things to me right to the Eureka
moment in the unit's own right
and kind of unanticipated so I thought I
might bring it up Trevor I had a
question for you about the Apple right
so isn't there a way that we can see the
language of 15 about in Palma right as a
resistance to what the machine is
clearly seeing right because the Machine
does not know the inside joke about the
art world about Rene Magritte's right
yeah so isn't there some kind of you
know push that's going on in many what I
was trying to know even in that
particular slide whereas like you can
read that Margarete image as a kind of a
funny thing about where he's making a
commentary about representation or
something like that but but you can also
but you can have a more political read
of that where he's showing you what is a
condition of possibility of a certain
kind of freedom and that freedom is to
define something or define it in a
different way right right and then no
and then like by putting the AI thing on
top of that I was saying like the kind
of freedom that Marguerite is trying to
enact in this image is foreclosed in
these kinds of systems right so that
that's what that was what kind of
logical showing nothing great all right
so we have some questions the first one
is for Trevor and it reads Murphy
suggests that a politics of consent for
the way data is used and manipulated is
that a possible way forward for
operational images and if so how it's a
sure I mean everything possible
theoretically I mean but um he hadn't I
don't I don't know and I and I hate it
I'm not a policy person you know I mean
I'm like it I feel bad sometimes because
it make these provocations and them say
like well I'm an artist not really my
problem and that's kind of my in thing
to do that but I don't know the answers
to these things that I don't know what's
reasonable to expect and I have like
very just fundamental questions about
this stuff at all like I friends of mine
very great and well-intentioned people
who work on data justice someone like
Kate Crawford or Julia and we're just
doing fantastically important work
looking at bias in machine learning and
that sort of thing and I kind of and
they're like this
I worry though about the whole project
in the first place I what is this
project of quantification like what is
this and and they would say yeah well
that's going to happen anyway like
quantified life that's always been the
saying like well you're bringing it into
further more and more intimate parts of
people's everyday lives right and you're
colonizing more and more kinds of spaces
that were previously outside of the
market and we're previously not visible
to state power and and I and I think
that that is very dramatic although
that's been a tendency that's been in
play for a very long time so I don't I
don't know and I don't but I know that
we need to think about it fair enough
another question I think it's just for
the panel how do we balance training
systems to see the full spectrum of
gender and race without building systems
that lend themselves toward profiling or
categorization that's the same thing
that's the point right is profiling
yes I mean you can you can create
systems that can see different and and
and actually difference can be a feature
of the system because what you're trying
to do is discriminate right like that
the point that's the feature of the
systems right so um so yeah I don't I
don't the same thing in my opinion Lisa
I was hoping you could say more about
this notion that the image is a
logistical field of operation now right
because it seems to me what that means
is that might be the dialectical
opposite of the slow movement of reading
and an analysis and
interpretation so I'm very afraid now I
mean there is a history of the clivus
in electronic media that precedes the
digital era and it really goes back to
radio right and even telephony for that
matter but I think what people who are
working in the field of logistical media
are interested in is the way in which
networked images that our lives became
are able to be you know acted upon
instantaneously in ways where there are
not decisions about ethics or
repercussions but the system's inherent
inherit pre-existing logics like a kind
of you know a system of government ality
gets orchestrated through live media
where a pattern of operations will kind
of sediment and be decided upon as
legitimate and viable and then be
mobilized through a live media interface
and you know we see this with drone
warfare a lot of there's a parody online
called the ethical governor where
basically drop the drone is completely
autonomous and has inherited an
architecture of decision-making that
ensures that its targets are rationally
and morally chosen and that the decision
to drop a bomb also is something that
has already been morally vetted and this
is a kind of you know apocalyptic
prognosis about the way that drone
warfare might manifest but it gives us a
space a kind of artistic parodic media
space to begin thinking through the
politics of drone warfare especially
when we look out the news headlines now
and I don't know if you've noticed there
was a lot of discussion of drone in the
headlines and from about 2009 to 2015
and now they're called air strikes the
actual word drone
has disappeared from headlines I've been
tracking this and they're called
airstrikes rather than drone strikes
because there were so much negative kind
of coverage about what their how they
were being used for targeted killing
programs and what the capacities are I
mean that's just one way of spending
that question and conversation is to
think about that set of issues here's
another question from the audience
Bratton call the shaping of AI as humans
humans bigotry can we in any way build
machine intelligence that through more
autonomous behavior can oppose powers
[Laughter]
I hope so maybe resistance is not futile
after all the service in question I mean
pudding if you go back I don't know
seventy years ago or so he defined the
AI as a kind of a interface where you
are talking to someone and you don't
know if it's a person or a machine but
if the machine can convince you that it
is a person then you call the Machine
intelligently roughly this is during
this definition but that this question I
do not know how to answer but it kind of
provokes the sort of the comparison if
the humans are sometimes expected to be
racist for example so the machine also
be racist I mean is it the desert of the
question or or how did you stop the
machine from the racist
you know I wish I could read this
person's mind I don't know but it does
provoke this comparison right a thought
which is I you know one of the the
questions that have been recurring in
this conference has been how to scale
things up right so how do we scale like
technologies up or it's like
intelligence up or how do we think about
like infrastructurally and we know the
kind of implicit desires that what we
want to do is scale things up right and
so when we ask these kind of questions
about like what do we do how do we do
politics this is kind of also implicit
thing that should work at this like
scaled-up level hmm and that you know if
we talk about like practices of consent
which are also practices of refusal that
it should be at the scaled up level it
should be about building a scaled up
system and so I think you know this is
something we can do about reflecting
about our theory of change here that we
have to you know we have to kind of wait
until we can have the scaled up solution
before
we're like satisfied with our politics I
think that there's a much more intimate
scales of non deferral for taking up
these questions where we don't have to
hold ourselves to the logic that it must
be
up in order to be doing something--in
the world so that's just the kind of a
thought about like the way we kind of
form the question about what we want out
of like technology and our relations to
it this is something that they meant to
ask that what about the very last thing
you mentioned that we train all the
systems or neural networks from the past
and I think this is what you're saying -
it was very very briefly at the end of
your presentation and mister there's
something very important that I had
never thought before can you elaborate
on that I mean how could we make
machines perhaps be more predictable or
actually more accepting of change when
when I said you can only try them from
train them from the past I decide I
think that the thing that I worry about
is that that's not an engineering
problem you know what I need
I mean I think that's a political
question right I mean ultimately all of
these are political questions including
all the engineering ones um but I don't
know I mean I think that I've heard
ideas around looking at the
optimizations that some of these things
are able to perform
they're so dramatic that I've heard
people say like there should be
something like you know nuclear
inspectors for AI and decide whether as
a society we want to perform this
operation or this optimization right do
we want to have self-driving trucks that
is going to completely collapse the
economy of the south right and just take
millions and millions of what are now
you know okay paid jobs out of the
economy and I think the proposal is like
that and we're getting to the point as a
society where you're making those
decisions one way or another we've
stuffed it maybe we should be more
conscious about that um and that we
shouldn't just leave it up to Burt to
decide that for the entire society all
right another question a CV system I
don't know what's easy
Sam's computer business not a CV system
that can't see a black girl is like
Morrison shopkeeper very good audience
do we have a responsibility to Train CV
to see diversity despite the risk of
discrimination I mean the question is
how are you going to use that right so I
mean the I mean we you want to see
diversity and we want to do that as a
way of trying to create more equality
right Julia Angwin again it pro-public
that just publish the article few weeks
ago that was looking at the codes and
auto insurance and guess what if you're
is if code with black people you're
paying 30% more for auto insurance even
if the insurance company is always
paying out less money for yes sir right
so yeah so that's seeing diversity in
order to create a predatory structure
all right so um sorry I think that for
me that's just the answer like what do
you what is that what you're trying to
do not what you're trying to see right
exactly what value you're placing on
what you're seeing okay does anybody
here have something that they are
hankering to say or share yeah
- thinking in our turn what oh hi and
then thinking how how odd it is to be
some of my generation that it was we
were we were always critiquing truth
yeah right and we're always trying to
dismantle truths and PluralEyes them etc
but since act like well truth has always
been something that is struggling for it
is never not trouble for never has been
not struggle for you know I mean to have
to have a black people seen as humans
that was a long centuries long struggle
and still going on you know
and I guess I'm wondering what how
different I mean I know this is what
you're trying to tell us is how
different it is now you know that like
how the terms of the struggle are
changed and we we need to wake up to
that that where we're at a kind of
disadvantage we've never been able to
even conceive of is that what you're
trying to say okay one more question
[Laughter]
what about the fact of say you know I
mean the killing of black men by the
police did not start in Ferguson of
course but everybody has videos now and
the same machine that takes the image
distributes the image and is there not
some kind of Hope in sorry I asked about
hope sorry
is there not some kind of thought that
you know there as we also become more
technologically enfranchised that
there's there are ways to counter or do
they just seem like that's preposterous
we will never there's there's ways to
counter of course but i guess i'm
worried about like is there an
underlying epistemological problem
which is like sure you can develop
quantitative system that can be like oh
well this cop just like broke this law
and therefore should get fired right and
this person just jaywalked and they
should get a ticket but what I'm
wondering if that's actually how we want
to think about solving these problems
because I would argue that sure you can
like make police brutality more visible
and thereby maybe make it go away but I
don't know if that's if you want to
think about kind of quantified solutions
to these sorts of problems because I
would probably argue that at the end of
the day you don't want to do that you
need to find ways that keep that ability
to contest the meaning of things and the
meaning of actions alive you know I
don't know I mean I'm just saying my
husband's affair about this fella I like
what Michelle says about counter
infrastructures and maybe thinking about
infrastructure that struggles and maybe
to answer Sandy's earlier question about
epiphanies I think one of the things
that I in retrospect realized might have
been an epiphany that helped me in some
way get toward convening this panel was
something that Donna Haraway wrote in
the in the 1990s in which she asked she
exhorted her readers to ask the question
with whose blood were my eyes crafted
and so a number of words jump out blood
which might sort of be about struggle
about histories of community about
infrastructures of struggle with whose
blood were my eyes crafted my the
question of who's speaking who's seeing
from where who was the we and then eyes
which are these technologically
described infrastructures of phenomena
at phenomenology and apprehension as
your invocation of Jonathan query
pointed us to earlier on sandy so
so I guess that was that was an epiphany
that maybe behind some of my thinking
about this what is what is struggle who
is the we and what are the technologies
of visibility and invisibility and those
are historically transforming so to
speak to Claire's query which is a query
about change in continuity there are
different kinds of infrastructures and
although there are continuities being
very keenly tuned to the technological
transformations and affordances even if
they're sort of just tactical rather
than strategic might be one way to think
maybe I could add something to that
which is you know working on chemical
exposures for some 25 years when I
started you know talking about the way
that chemical exposures are rendered and
perceptible that was something that took
a lot of work to show people and now you
know when we you know have that kind of
argument next to like the kinds of
things that Trevor and Lisa are talking
about the way we manifest our ability to
visible eyes violence seems absurd our
system for understanding chemical
violence or for understanding invisible
izing externalities and economic
processes our system of like invisible
izing racial violence and white
supremacy all those systems are now
seeming more and more absurd and legible
to people and so there's something even
though those processes have been
happening for maybe hundreds of years
there is something that I find a
potential there in that they do seem
more absurd and untenable to uphold at
this moment to more people and so I take
some kind of energy from that thought
there's a flipside to that if you could
actually visualize them like if you
could see the dangerous particles around
us or in the water boy would pay much
more attention to the rain exactly
exactly I mean we would live in a really
different world if we were visible izing
industrially produced exposures that are
spinning constantly doggers fired I
guess but not the point it was the thing
is it happening constantly mmm that's
the recipe basically for taking things
for granted natasha has a question I
guess I want to ask thinking too you
know the images of the number of bodies
on the mall and inauguration day and
then I was struck also during Michelle's
talk by the the Canada's list of
chemicals and I almost wanted more like
I wanted the pages to go on more and
more and I see Trevor nodding but I'm
pushing back on him on something he said
with where I'm going with this which is
a lot of that was about quantification
and about counting and so I'm wondering
do we want to you've said a few times
that you don't know that quantification
is the way forward so I want to ask you
but also Michelle and anyone else who
wants to jump in whether you know is
quantification the thing that we want to
turn into a problem here or is it more
the automation of interpretation that's
right Automation of interpretation oh
that was an easy like obviously the
question hand I have a question for true
as well and I was wondering and you as
an artist if you ever struggle if
there's a struggle that you're just
exposing these images and working with
these images and the fact that you could
also make the choice of be an activist
and do something about it and how are
you dealing with this struggle yeah I
mean so I I don't struggle with it
because I work with lots of the
activists and this work is very much
alongside that kind of work so it's
that's always been a part of these
projects having said that I do want to
live in a world where art is not
can be something other than like
instrumentalized in the service like a
political project or something like that
and I'm not sure that that's actually
possible but I would like to live in a
world like that and I would like to live
in a world in which you can make images
that are self contradictory or that are
complicated or that um that put you in
the viewer is in the situation where you
have to ask yourself what you think
you're seeing or what you what your
relationship to that that that kind of
thing is um so yeah I mean all of the
all of the projects that I've ever done
pretty much in my life have been done in
to one extent or another in
collaboration that it with different
kind of people doing activism whether
that's Human Rights Watch or reprieve or
the Center for Constitutional Rights I
mean there's a long long list of people
that I've collaborated with over the
years on this stuff um but that doesn't
but I also think that we can have like
divisions of labor and the day we can
have a society two hours artists in it
and that those artists can do things
that are different than what activists
do and that's different than what policy
people are doing your would through what
we're all happy and you're writing till
you talk a little bit about work by like
Adam Harvey you know artists who are
developing ways of jamming biometric
facial recognition systems by either
designing masks that confound those
machine vision systems or but there are
low-tech versions of this too that are
you know just the hoodie
a lot of people you know where the
hoodie or the anonymous mask to try to
not be recognized when they're at mass
demonstrations and protests where they
know that there might be police cams
mobilized another technology being used
that these now are the emcee catchers as
well the cell fight simulators which are
also being blended with uh with camera
capture systems there's a system called
Sura catch where you can post it on an
electrical light pole it just looks like
a ordinary electric box but it actually
has a camera embedded inside and an MC
catcher that catch
the you know international mobile phone
subscriber identity of each person that
passes in its vicinity so it has all the
numbers of everybody's phones while it
also captures wide-shots
video footage and these systems were
mobilized a lot after the Boston bombing
because the police had to crowdsource
cell phone video in order to run that
material through systems and try to
identify suspects so now there are these
blending of you know cell phone
interception apparatus with machine
vision captures airport in Dubai when
you go into customs if you have your
phone on it there's mzk to associate
your phone with a picture that it takes
of your face when you get there customs
the Bengie feelings and like de gotcha
so yeah I mean I started that by saying
like recently thinking of how one can
put something on the face to resist
identification and I do think there's a
lot of artists Trevor and other artists
really exploring how to develop
resistances to these systems so this
question was typed twice so I'm going to
read it as urgency and it is is a
politics of consent and consensus a
means or an end consensus can be very
very wrong after all I look here you
talk about that for me you know when we
think about consent and they with
imaging and that kind of thing we think
a consent forms and these ways of like
saying yes but I think you know when you
come out of other kinds of struggles
consent is about also like the right to
refusal and the power of saying no are
not giving or holding in a ban so
holding back so that kind of complicates
what we mean when we're coming together
around questions of a politics of
consent
in terms of consensus I don't think you
know I've been in a Women and Gender
Studies department for a long time we
operate by consensus I'm very aware of
its many dysfunctions at the same time
part of what it's I think the the
interesting thing about having modes of
consensus and we have many different
ways like just how do you operate your
github can be thinking about modes of
consensus you know how do we make
protocols that are making explicit
relations of decision-making in
community and we've talked a lot about
you know democratizing technology and I
think you know consensus democracy can
sometimes hide these kind of hard
questions about like how do we actually
make kind of protocols that recognize
power and struggle always inadequately
to do things together in community so I
would think that's what consensus puts
on the table is that kind of necessity
of you know having those hard decisions
about what is your protocol for your
github or what is your protocol for
deciding how you're going to
collectively edit the document or
whatever it is well that's our time I'm
not a journalist and I would just rather
the quality code of consensual you reach
also depends on the infrastructure or
the culture that you have in place among
the group of people right and maybe it
works better than you are Department
than my department but democratizing
technology means you can catch the cups
when they do buy things it also means
you can broadcast aquiline on Facebook
right so you know it really depends on
how society is set up and operates well
if you have a process of consensus you
have a responsibility to actually you
know that I if you have a process
questions you're not going to reach
consensus all the time but you have a
responsibility as participants to say to
each other what you're doing is not
right or what you're doing has this
implication you have a responsibility to
kind of call each other out and in to
the responsibilities in your actions and
that is messy it's uneasy it
discomforting you know it's easier to be
in spaces where we're all being like
polite and collegial not talking about
like the power in the room and it's much
harder to be in spaces were responsible
eyes to doing that in you know our
activities of knowledge making so we
don't have to get along to have a
process of consensus making if we don't
reach consensus is better to have the
process anyways thank you since we're
being naughty and going over time anyway
I just I just wanted to put this
question in the air because I think it's
a good question it doesn't have to be
answered now unless somebody wants to
answer it but the question is this you
didn't say if the glue were to go
you didn't save the list of chemicals in
the water were at anything like unsafe
levels isn't chemo phobia part of the
problem in public knowledge good motion
okay so I didn't say at the list of
chemicals where I said Ian we're at
anything like unsafe levels isn't chemo
phobia part of the problem in public
knowledge
and I'm guessing chemo phobias people
being afraid chemical people being
afraid of chemicals I worry about chemo
phobias being another kind of gas
lighting thing so there's a long history
of calling people who are worried about
like the violence in their world
hysterical oversensitive angry and we
have a problem that I know very well for
my own work in the words of many
colleagues that are threshold levels for
deciding safety the whole history behind
how we decide those are so filled with
politics they're so filled with an
effort to not regulate chemicals so for
example in the United States the EPA has
not successfully had a kind of
prohibition on a chemical since 1989 at
the same time 15,000 new patentable
substances are introduced into the
american chemical registry every day so
are the scope of our not understanding
about you know what is safe or put a
different way what does it mean to be
homo toxicant is so profound that you
know that is the showing those numbers
is it just a heuristic join those two
different lists of just Urist ik to get
you thinking that don't take those lists
as to telling ask questions thank you so
it's great answer and thank you anyone
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Applause]